foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's got lots of content don't you know
search a subject but don't forget to add
his name at the end of the subject if
you're thinking about joining the David
Pac-Man show he's got the content don't
you know search a subject but don't
forget to add his name at the end of the
search criteria
foreign
[Music]
la la la la la la la la
[Music]
la
la la la la la la la la la la la la la
[Music]
la la la la
how are you looking for a place to watch
some news where people don't yell while
wearing suits I know of a guy who fits
that bill of progressive with political
will but David pectin shows you your
political knowledge sign up for a
membership now for the bonus
who's the current president of the
United States
who's the current president well I guess
um I guess it's a funny it's a funny
question
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
time to pluck it
foreign
[Music]
mangoes
[Music]
I love mangoes too
now that we are we under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now costs
[Music]
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango art mangoes
eight or eleven bucks
[Music]
bring my man goes back down
[Music]
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified with the
mangoes
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what you doing
[Music]
well it is debate month in America we
are getting very very close to the 2022
midterms just I guess hours away no days
weeks certainly and tonight we have a
really important debate this is the Ohio
Senate debate wherein JD Vance the
author of hillbilly elegy is facing off
against our friend I'm comfortable
calling him that Congressman Tim Ryan
who has been a guest on this program and
we had a beautiful uh conversation at
some conference years ago that I can't
even really remember uh the race is
sadly
Too Close you know in a let's actually
pull that up in a normal country
JD Vance would be getting humiliated
right now but indeed Vance is up by 1.4
points that's JD Vance now you see that
there are two right-leaning polls that
are part of this 1.4 point lead
but it's still not looking particularly
good for Tim Ryan and Ohio is a state
for whom voting for Republican Senators
is not
particularly rare okay so
um that's what's going on uh super chats
are already dumping in will I be
covering the Los Angeles mayoral uh
probably not I have so much on my plate
that I probably will not be covering
that I apologize I do
Espress with a 69 Super Chat says user
lame from pacord
wants to hear you say 69 oh boy
quite a quite a day quite a day now if
you didn't realize that his name was JD
Vance it might be because of this viral
moment where Donald Trump proudly
announced that he had endorsed
JD Vance but
he didn't know his name remember this
that's what they're waiting for they're
waiting for One race you know we've
endorsed Dr Oz we've endorsed
JP right JD Mandel and he's doing great
they're all doing good yeah now that was
a portmanteau of uh Josh Mandel
and JD Vance they were running against
each other
and it was so boneheaded because they
were both fighting for Trump's
endorsement for a while
and imagine being
uh JD Vance you finally get the
endorsement and Trump sort of mentions
the other guy's name like just
completely completely humiliating but
that is what took place General update
oh and by the way the debate's only an
hour long it starts in 20 minutes it'll
be a nice tight stream for everybody
um in terms of the latest numbers
Democrats are slightly favored to win
the Senate uh roughly a two to one
chance but uh things that are
34 percent likely to happen happen all
the time uh the most likely outcomes are
somewhere between Democrats having 50
and 53 seats or Republicans having 51 or
52 seats and then less likely Democrats
at 54 or 55 seats even less likely
Republicans at 53 54 or 55 seats so
that's the Senate that's the Senate and
then over in the House Republicans by
roughly two to one margin favored to win
and I believe that that's the outcome
that we are ultimately going to see
all right everybody
thank you to S Perez for kicking us off
beautifully with 20 gifted subscriptions
and a big thank you to your billion for
the twitch Prime subscription also
thanks to Kevin gouldi and Jason
sickmeyer each of them gifting a
subscription at joinpakman.com putting
us at 23 today's coupon code because it
is really important to vote
the coupon code today
is Big voting
big voting 22.
use the code at joinpakman.com it'll go
really well for you okay really well
Bronx is going into Manhattan soon got
to get out of the cave in Brooklyn any
restaurants that are favorites no pizza
please oh I have so many uh you know 282
burger and a Smith Street bagels and
actually a lot of them are pizza places
but I have videos on my Brooklyn
recommendations
uh extensive list extensive list will
Tim Ryan humiliate Vance for Trump
calling him an ass kisser I hope so
here's my concern tonight and I would
love for you fine folks to let me know
in the chat whether you share the
concern
um Tim Ryan isn't a great debater
uh JD Vance slash JP Mandel is horrible
really really horrible
but Ryan is not the best debater and I'm
worried that it won't go well for him
tonight I'm genuinely worried
so we'll stand by and see thanks to
Jackson Corvette for the twitch Prime
subscription appreciate that
uh thanks to chair fender for the Super
Chat as well let's look at a couple of
other things that I have here for you as
we wait for the debate there was a Sarah
Palin rally yesterday and you might be
saying wait a second Sarah Palin lost
she lost the special election but now
she's in the normal one
it was a mostly empty room
like everything about this is crazy and
they had some of the strangest
entertainers look at this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a James Brown impersonator in
case anybody was wondering
um
Alex Jones came up with some stuff don't
really care about that
I did have a bunch of other things to
play for you guys let me see if I can
get to some of them
uh stuff about a feminate man it's just
we're so boring so so boring
uh let me get to some of my other things
this is my curated list here
um oh here is Marjorie Trader green
weighing in on the Kanye controversy
[Music]
yeah Kanye he's out there with uh Kanye
because Kanye is wearing the shirt white
lives matter
you should just stick with all lives
matter right all right
all right really interesting commentary
from her as you can imagine I will be
doing a segment we were off today for
the holiday I'll be doing a segment
tomorrow on uh
the entire Kanye thing for sure for sure
um Candace Owens weighed in on the tweet
that was the tweets
and people subsequently demanded that
the Tweet be taken down for
anti-Semitism now if you are it was very
anti-Semitic
honest person
you did not think this tweet was
anti-semitic you did not think that he
wrote this feat because he by the way
what's with people saying Semitic
it's Semitic anti-Semitic
anyway thanks or wanted to genocide
Jewish people this is not represent the
beginning of a holocaust that's if
you're an honest person you'll meet that
you will admit that right if you're an
honest person when you read this tweet
you had no idea what the hell he was
talking about I had I had no idea it was
pretty clear he was basically saying
he's going after Jews idea when I read
this tweet what the hell he was talking
about this tweet inspired questions not
answers first she's like my lack of
reading comprehension means it wasn't
anti-semitic what is death Con 3
did he mean deaf Con 3 which would be a
military defense position not an offense
for those of you that are offended a
military he was gonna defend himself
against the Jews conspiring against him
rather than attack the Jews conspiring
against him oh okay Jesus defense
position is he tweeting this because
he's reading the Newsweek headline
calling him an anti-semitic is he angry
because he can't believe it he's not
free to talk about people in his life
who happen to be Jewish
foreign
all the people holding him down just
happened to be Jewish and he should be
able to talk about that right is there
Judaism relevant to that being accused
of anti-Semitism is he saying I'm not
going to shut up and I'm going to keep
tweeting and I'm Gonna Keep Calling
these people out well he's not gonna
keep tweeting he was banned referring to
his friends that he feels slighted by is
he talking about Jerry Kushner and Josh
Kushner
if you're a liar you'll say I know I was
scared of Candace I actually thought
that Kanye West was going to launch a
military strike in Israel you know you
don't have to think that Kanye's coming
after you specifically
to understand that that was insanely
anti-Semitic
um other super chats coming in Tim says
hope Tim Ryan is better prepared than
Mark Kelly Kelly had good moments but
overall rough very rough very rough
David sir I come to you with tears in my
eyes if Trump wins the 24 election is it
possible he pardons himself of all these
legal issues I don't want to go down the
road of the self-pardon stuff again
because
it's just not worth it it's just not
worth it that it was a big Topic at one
point thank you to Jason sickmeyer for
gifting another subscription at
joinpakman.com also thank you to
Independent NN for the twitch Prime
subscription folks we have a really
modest goal tonight
to keep our debate streams almost
nightly going of 100
let's just do it okay the coupon code is
Big voting 22. let's see what else we
have here
um
Trump interview don't care about
had a couple other things
a lot of culty very culty stuff
oh this is good from our friends over at
the good liars it sounds like you were
just turned away from the event can you
tell us about that uh we went in and
they told me that my shirt was not
candidate endorsed so you showed up to
this jump rally and essentially you got
canceled because of the shirt you were
wearing simply because the shirt nothing
but the shirt how do you feel about that
I have a problem with it and to me it's
giving in to the council culture and I
refuse to give into the cancel culture
will you vote Trump if he runs in 2024
now I don't know I will not I cannot be
a part of cancel culture wow well at
least he's uh at least he's sticking to
his principles as far as I understand
them as far as he understands them or
something like that here's a funny video
I have never seen this but apparently in
this clip this is old Trump tries to
Bluff his way into saying he read a book
he very obviously didn't read let's
watch this together who are your
favorite authors
well I have a number of favorite authors
I think Tom Wolf is excellent did you
read did you read vanity the bonfires I
did not it's it's a phenomenal book what
book are you reading now bonfire the
vanishes I'm reading my own book again
because I think it's so fantastic Thomas
who what's the best what's the best book
you've read beside art of the deal
um I I really like Tom Will's last book
and uh I think I think he's a great
author he's uh he's done a beautiful job
he's what's the name of the book which
book he's uh his current book his his
just his current book it's just out
bonfire the vanities yes and and uh
didn't he wait hold on wasn't that the
one he said he didn't read
did you read vanity of the bonfires I
did not
oh that's genius he's uh he's done a
beautiful job he's Rich Brooke he's uh
his current book his his just his
current book it's just out bonfire the
vanities yes and and uh the uh the man
has done a a very very good job and I
don't I I really can't hear with his
earphone by the way yeah I don't know
what your favorite offer I couldn't hear
the name of it but that's the one I read
I also didn't read it earlier in the
interview man that's really that's
something else huh that's really good
really really really good
uh man that's I was not familiar with
that but that is good stuff
uh well Crime and Punishment really
wow wouldn't that be shy like to be
genuinely surprised
it would be amazing if someday Trump was
like you know
I read Crime and Punishment and what
Dostoyevsky is able to do
with what's what's the character's name
is it raskolnikov do you guys remember
what it what the is that the main
character
in crime and punishment raskolnikov
anyway let's imagine it is it would be
unbelievable if sometime Trump was just
asked about books and he said you know
the book I really go back to is crime
and punishment because just the picture
of Russia in which Dostoyevsky places
raskolnikov quite frankly it really
reminds me of some of the stories I've
read uh about the Soviet Union actually
before the fall of the wall like you
know imagine that he made some kind of
analysis it doesn't matter if it's
accurate or whatever anyway he doesn't
read we know that he doesn't read thanks
to Blake Daniel as well as who's this
Johnny manogue each gifting a
subscription at joinpakman.com numbers
27 and 28. really appreciate that
other super chats coming in
um Juni asks why does the right have to
defend every indefensible statement
who's on their team what I appreciate
about you David and other lefties is you
criticize everyone regardless if they're
on your team or not I do and some in my
audience don't like it one bit
they don't like it one bit all right
couple other things before
we move on to the debate
uh what else did I have here for you
a couple of these things are from
yesterday
not this one
there's some really wacky stuff that's
been floating around
Ed Henry I guess got fired it's like who
cares you know whatever just I can't
even keep up with the right wing media
drama
the Bannon thing I'm gonna skip
Putin's stuff we're doing tomorrow maybe
I don't have that much else for you guys
right now oh Maria Bartiromo to her
credit she did say that the Kanye tweet
is is bad a West setting uh is getting
suspended
from Twitter he got suspended yesterday
after an anti-semitic rant that violated
company policies West tweeted this I'm a
bit sleepy tonight but when I wake up
I'm going Defcon 3 on Jewish people by
the way there's something about Maria
Bartiromo reading the tweet
I I just love it I don't know why it's
it the the Tweet is even more absurd
when read by Maria Bartiromo the funny
thing is I I actually can't be
anti-semitic because black people are
actually Jew the
her disbelief at Jew singular I love
that black people are actually Jew oh
God this is amazing the funny thing is I
actually can't be anti-semitic because
black people are actually Jew
the treating question has been deleted
the suspension from Twitter comes after
West was knocked off of Instagram on
Friday because he was wearing a white
lives matter shirt again over the
weekend digging I mean the White lives
matter sure I don't have a problem with
but what is this what is this tweet
uh Kanye West this is the New York
posters reporting and I'll just read the
headline friends are certain that Kanye
West is in the middle of a psychiatric
episode
oh man I mean he's been in the middle of
one for six what six years four years
right I mean it's absurd
it's been going on for a very very long
time we are moments away from a very
very powerful debate we are we are you
know tracking rainfall and all of these
different things it's very exciting
thanks to Mr vister for the twitch Prime
subscription putting us at 29. also
thank you to Blake Daniel for gifting a
subscription on my website remember that
the top way the best way to support my
work
is signing up at joinpakman.com coupon
code it's don't I don't have to push you
into it but it's available big voting 22
and it saves you a bundle it is tonight
JD Vance versus our friend Tim Ryan if
you didn't remember that that's the name
of the candidate it's because of this
that's what they're waiting for they're
waiting for One race you know we've
endorsed Dr Oz we've endorsed
JP right JD Mandel and he's doing great
they're all Trump didn't know the name
of the guy he endorsed and that's why
you may now be finding yourself confused
I know that there are hundreds of
voicemails that I have not listened to
let's see if we can listen to
like a couple of them okay
hey David it's Tommy just thinking about
Ohio and I think our best bet
to win in Ohio is for you to reach out
to the voters of Ohio and tell them to
write in JP Mandel as they write in on
the election you know what's really
funny about that if there was a write-in
campaign for JP Mandel
I bet you that if a Vance lost they
would try to argue that because Trump
referred to him as JP Mandel the JP
Mandel write-ins should be counted for
Vance you know they would try to do that
there is not a doubt in the world that
they would try to make that case if they
lost
uh pretty pathetic pretty pathetic
David sir the other day you were talking
about the possibility of getting a
billboard yeah and I thought it would be
a good idea to get a billboard in an
area where you know that Alex Jones is
going to see it and advertise the world
famous bonus show it would be amazing if
we could figure out where Alex Jones
drives in order to get to work and we
put a huge billboard with my face there
I don't think it would be smart to
mention Jones because
it could just cause legal trouble if we
mention him in some way I don't think
that's a good idea but the idea of
putting up a billboard somewhere where
Alex Jones would see it driving to work
that's a great idea
Texas huge fan I'm the one that left the
message yesterday and I said Don't Play
this because I messed up big time
um I wanted you to
take a look at
this uh place that used to be called
Enterprise Square it's in Edmond
Oklahoma and it's basically a museum of
capitalism it gave me terrible
nightmares as a child I went there on
field trips several times
um it's just it's a fever dream all
right well I'll check into that uh maybe
after after the stream other super chats
coming in just moments away from the
debate sinsu I was asked today what's my
most important issue for the midterms
there's so many but it becomes moot if
we don't do what's necessary to ensure
the planet can sustain human life well
said
well said hey by the way I start this is
just a little kind of an FYI I started a
new book last night by an author named
Saul Herzog and it's a pen name and
apparent like the book says it's a pen
name for a really well-known writer and
when I Googled it
I could not find out who it's a pen name
for if anybody wants to dual I'm curious
if anybody wants to do a little research
uh
uh who who is Saul Herzog who is the
author it just kind of a curiosity
uh okay bay photo says former executive
and VP of Yeezy at Adidas John Wexler
took part in a Twitter space's
discussion yesterday not one word about
Kanye's on anti-Semitism disappointing
how few in Kanye's circles are speaking
out well said
David sir I'm writing to you with tears
in my eyes I can't watch the stream
because I have tears in my eyes please
help I would try a napkin
I would try a napkin amen
uh yeah oh it's the author is JP Mandel
that's interesting that's interesting
that actually makes a lot of sense
uh thanks to Blake Daniel for gifting
another
website membership at joinpakman.com we
are moments away from the debate
reminder JD Vance leading by about 1.4
Tim Ryan not necessarily known as a
particularly good debater I'm hoping
that he is prepared today uh let's see
if we have other voicemails
hey David I'm watching your live stream
and I overheard the billboard area
seeking I don't know if Alex Jones lives
in Austin but years ago I met his nephew
or his cousin or someone related to him
they're actually affiliated with
Infowars and have been on the show I
can't remember his name at the top of my
head but I dropped off one of his
friends at his place so I somewhat know
the vicinity of someone related to Alex
Jones well we could look into that now
for people saying that Saul Herzog is
actually Saul Bellow
I I know why you're saying that because
I know what comes up when you Google it
Saul Bellow died in 2005.
and he is not a well-known Thriller
writer and some of the books by Saul
Herzog are newer I think the reason that
comes up when you Google it is that Saul
Bellow has a book named Herzog so it is
a I believe that it's a Google
um confusion I don't believe that Saul
Herzog could be the pen name for Saul
Bello because Bello died 17 years ago
and the Saul Herzog books are newer than
that some of them anyway some of them
anyway okay so everybody who's sending
me that info please please take it easy
thanks to Blake Daniel for another
gifted website membership and thanks to
Thomas Tosh for gifting a website
membership putting us at 33 which is a
fantastic number
a couple other
voicemails here
let me see what else I've got
um
making sure I don't put anything that's
inappropriate here
hey David I was watching a recent stream
of yours and you had used the term or
I'm not I'm sorry um someone on your
show had uses her neurodivergent
okay and now this is something I really
take ombres with David
um these people are not neurodivergent
these people are a stop on our society
oh my God uh
uh what the hell is going on
I'm gonna get away from that in fact I'm
going to block that caller
uh yeah that's not that's not for this
show uh
please never never leave a message like
that again
NH Barrick says I know you don't time
markets but unusual whales Twitter
trying to get tickers crows and nank to
track politician stock trading they are
buying stock in meds for nuclear related
treatment things yeah but the reason
they're doing that isn't necessarily
because they believe they're going to be
needed but it's because governments are
stockpiling those meds because of
Vladimir Putin's belligerence so make of
that what you will
Juni also have you seen Bill Burr's
comments on socialism and capitalism if
so what are your thoughts I have not
seen those
I have not seen those
uh David what is your reading routine I
tend to read left to right top to bottom
and turn the pages to the left as I've
completed them
how do you make time for books in a
world of attention Merchants oh I just
it's I just make time I read at least 25
pages of non-fiction every day
and then I also read fiction before
going to bed
so
what is going on with this debate ah
here we go often their first Statewide
debate JD Vance
and Tim Ryan
your local election headquarters and
broadcast across the Buckeye State this
is the Ohio Senate debate you are
looking at a live picture of downtown
Cleveland for this very special night of
political conversation and debate we are
now four weeks away from election day
early voting in Ohio begins on Wednesday
good evening I'm Lou maglio and the
studios of wjw Fox 8 you're watching us
on air or online for one of five next
star media stations in Ohio we are
broadcasting to Cleveland Columbus
Dayton Youngstown and Steubenville plus
partner stations in Cincinnati and
Toledo you've met the candidates taking
part in What will be the only Statewide
debate for Ohio's open U.S Senate seat
now let's meet the moderators tonight
Colleen Marshall from NBC four in
Columbus and Joe Tui from Fox 8 here in
Cleveland thank you so much Lou and
Welcome to our candidates and to all of
you who are watching across the state
you can follow along using the hashtag
oh send debate you'll find additional
information supporting tonight's
questions now let's start with a quick
rundown of the rules for our debate so
you at home can know what to expect
tonight's debate will be divided into
topics with a goal of five minutes of
discussion time for each moderators will
be allowed to jump in to ensure equal
time to answer within that five-minute
window this format was proposed by the
Ryan campaign and agreed to by the Vance
campaign wow now you might hear the
sound of a bell when it's time to move
on to the next topic each
cat will get one minute for a closing
statement the order was determined by a
card draw JD vets you get the first
question and we do begin tonight with
the state of the economy every poll
shows the issue of inflation is by far
the number one concern among voters the
cost of everything from food to housing
through energy is all that's a rise Mr
Vance you have said as far back as July
you believe the nation is already in a
recession you blame that on Reckless
Democratic spending look at this however
some of these policies including the
infrastructure infrastructure bill will
provide tens of billions of dollars for
things in Ohio like clean water airports
and highways do you think some of that
money is well spent
well of course some of the money is well
spent but when you're talking about six
trillion dollars there's a lot of money
that isn't well spent and that's
fundamentally the problem with what
we've seen out of the body
Administration is simultaneously they've
borrowed and spent trillions of dollars
that we just don't have and that's
thrown fuel on the flyer fire of the
inflation problem and at the same time
they've completely gone to war against
America's energy sector and you can't do
both of those things at the same time
they're each bad ideas but when you do
both of them at the same time you're
going to get record inflation which is
exactly what you expect to get now Tim
Ryan of course has supported all of
these policies a hundred percent of the
time and this really is the contrast on
these economic issues between Tim Ryan
and myself I believe we've gone in a
fundamentally bad Direction over the
last couple of years I think people
deserve to go to the grocery store
without it completely breaking the bank
Tim Ryan has voted with these policies
100 of the time every single time he
gets an opportunity to stand up for Ohio
and he chooses to bend the knee to his
own party thank you Mr Jones Congressman
Ryan a similar question to you you heard
it there Republicans say during the Buy
Administration you voted for every one
of these spending bills to come out of
Washington they say they're Reckless do
you believe they've contributed to
inflation well let's look at what they
are a bipartisan infrastructure bill
that's going to create 600 000 jobs here
in Ohio JD Vance is against that Rob
Portman the senator who currently holds
a seat a republican helped put that deal
together look at the chips act lands the
Intel project that's going to create a
hundred billion dollar investment into
Ohio that's going to Ripple throughout
this entire Economy Supply chains
average wage 135 000 a year look at the
inflation reduction act and of course JD
is going to kick this campaign off with
misrepresenting my position in the
inflation reduction act that we're going
all in on natural gas I've been a
natural gas proponent since I've been in
Congress and and we have to get this
right we need to increase our production
of natural gas I support streamlining
the permitting process around natural
gas so that we can get it around the
country lower costs for businesses and
ship it to Europe to stick our finger in
Vladimir Putin's eyes so our allies but
here's the problem JD Vance has invested
into companies in China the problem
we're having now with inflation is our
supply chains all went to China and guys
like him have made a lot of money off
that and that is exactly why the supply
chains are locked up so far so working
with these bills to bring production
back well done we are going to talk a
little bit about China and the next
question for you Mr Vance in your 2016
book hillbilly elegy you called the idea
that all the jobs that went to China One
of quote the lies that we tell ourselves
in this campaign you have labeled China
as the enemy and implied they're taking
over jobs and Ohio Farmland where is
that happening and can you tell us
specifically well look absolutely China
is stealing our jobs China has stolen a
big chunk of our industrial and
Manufacturing base what I said my book
is something I still believe today that
that's not the only thing that's going
on but of course it's a huge big part of
the problem I ask why has China taken a
huge amount of America's jobs well one
of the reasons is because energy is too
expensive you cannot do modern
industrial manufacturing without high
quality energy Tim Ryan just told a big
FIB he said he supported Ohio's natural
gas industry and he's always done so and
yet Tim Ryan when he ran for president
was it two years ago you supported
Banning fracking both on public lands
and generally speaking that crushes the
Ohio energy sector and that's one of the
reasons why manufacturers are going to
China another reason Ohio manufacturers
go to China is because the Chinese
undercut American wages the only way to
really combat that is tariffs which I've
supported and now Tim Ryan supports it
I'm glad that you do Tim but of course
in 2018 2019 and 2020 you oppose the
tariffs that started to bring some of
that manufacturing and Industrial base
back to Ohio Ohio China is a big big
issue but China's problems are
exacerbated by our own leadership's
failures those failures go back 20 years
to when Tim Ryan started in Congress
they certainly go back the last couple
years when Joe Biden took over thank you
Mr Vance Congressman Ryan uh Republicans
as you say they blame President Biden
for a lot of the inflation problems you
told Colleen here in an interview last
week a few days ago that you we need new
leadership across the board you don't
believe he should run again do you think
President Biden is to blame for the
inflation crisis well I think
everybody's to blame I mean we're coming
out of a pandemic it's a problem the
question is we're going to sit around
for another 10 years and point fingers
what I've been proposing is a
significant tax cut for working people
and small businesses put money in
people's pockets we can sit there and
argue about why it's here it's a global
phenomenon right now we need to cut
taxes for working people okay and the
bottom line is he didn't answer the
question we have our supply chains in
Asia JD Vance invested in in China
and ships product and companies that
ship products back that's why we can't
get out of this inflation problem and as
far as natural gas goes once again two
questions two lies uh from JD I have for
my entire career supported tariffs on
China one of my first bills I had was to
penalize China uh for manipulating their
currency I work to get tariffs on
China's uh steel coming in that led to a
billion dollar investment in the
Youngstown Steel Mill and I supported
generally Trump's position on China in
Chinese terrorists while he's investing
in China and making money I'm trying to
fight these guys and the same with
natural gas because he brought it up you
could go back my entire career we have
two natural gas power plants in my
congressional district that I helped us
get in the union that works in the
natural gas industry endorsed me do you
think they're going to endorse me if I'm
for Banning fracking and just push not
true do you one President Biden to run
again in 2024. no I've been very clear
I'd like to see a generational change
Mitch McConnell Donald Trump the
president everybody like we need a new
generation gentlemen it's time to move
on to a new question and this is an area
where there is a very clear dividing
line between the two of you and it is
abortion our latest poll shows that this
is the number two issue for voters here
in Ohio
representative Ryan you are campaigning
as an abortion rights supporter you
might have to legislate that if you are
elected so what limits if any do you
support on abortion I support going back
to Roe v Wade that was established law
for 50 years and we didn't have all the
chaos that we're having now we read at
least a couple articles every week of
young people underage girls who have
been raped or women who have had
significant problems with their
pregnancy not be able to get help in the
state they got to go to Indiana they got
to go to Illinois
and that's not good enough for JD Vance
he supports a National Abortion ban in
which he wants women to have to get a
passport and go to Canada like we've got
to have some moderation on this issue
he's got a very extreme position JD you
called rape inconvenience right that's
rape is not inconvenient it's a
significant tragedy and he thinks that
we should have Ohio state law which says
if you're raped or incest pregnant
through incest that you should be forced
to have the baby this is the largest
governmental overreach in the history of
our lifetime complete violation of
personal freedom and liberty of women in
this state and I think we should
maintain that right and I think we
should make sure that none of the
extremists get to the United States
Senate we should codify Roe v Wade all
right so far so good I want to ask you
one of your Republican colleagues
Senator Lindsey Graham is proposing a
15-week National Abortion ban is that
something you could support at the
15-week point well first of all I did
not call rape inconvenient Congressman
Ryan knows that's not true but let me
just address my my view very
specifically and I'll answer the
question about Lindsey Graham's
legislation so look I am pro-life I've
always been pro-life and I I grew up in
a poor family and a poor Community I saw
a lot of young women have abortions when
I was growing up and one of the things
that always struck me is it felt like a
lot of those young women didn't have
options they felt like they didn't have
the health care that they needed we got
to fix that they felt like it would have
ruined to have a baby so early would
have ruin their career their personal
lives we've got to fix that sense too I
I recognize of course that a lot of
people are pro-choice that they have a
different view on this issue than I did
I was raised by a woman the woman who
saved my life my mammal uh was a woman
an old school Democrat who believed that
abortion should be safe legal and rare
that's not Congressman Ryan's view he
says that he wants to codify Roe he
voted for a piece of legislation that
would have overturned Roe and required
abortion on demand at 40 weeks for fully
elective reasons he also voted for a
piece of legislation that would have
prevented doctors from providing Medical
Care to babies who survived botched
abortions now on the Lindsey Graham Bill
my view on this is generally speaking
Ohio is going to want to have different
abortion laws than California than Texas
oh and I think I think Ohio should have
that right but some minimum National
Standard is totally fine with me we're
talking about five-month-old babies
fully formed babies who can feel pain no
civilized country in the world allows
elective abortion that late in pregnancy
the United States should be an exception
well thank you Mr Vance Congressman Ryan
in 2009 uh you wrote an op-ed describing
yourself as quote a pro-life member of
Congress why the change
I had some very personal conversations
with women in Ohio who had
gone through tragedies who needed to
have abortions for a variety of
different reasons and I just came to
realize through the course of these
conversations that the government has no
place in this matter
that this needs to be left to the woman
it needs to be left to the doctor to
make these decisions and I think isn't
this what we want from our leaders
people who listen people who learn from
experiences and then maybe have a change
of position uh that to me is is really
important but we can't ignore the level
of extremism that we're hearing from JD
Vance on this position no exceptions for
rape and incest right if you get raped
JD Vance and others are going to say you
have to have that baby State mandated
pregnancies for a rape victim that is so
far out of the mainstream it's not even
funny let me address that let me go back
to Mr Vance to find out about this you
have said in the past that you compared
uh abortion to slavery even in the case
of the ten-year-old Ohio girl that made
headlines across the country you said
two wrongs don't make a right it sounds
tonight as if you're saying there are
some exceptions I would accept can you
specifically tell us what you might
accept as an exception look I've always
believed in reasonable exceptions this
is a misrepresentation in my view but
let's hear it from me it's not from
Congressman Ryan uh I I absolutely think
the 10 year old girl the case that we've
of course heard a lot about an
incredibly tragic situation I mean look
I've got a nine-year-old baby girl at
home I cannot imagine what's that what
that's like for the girl for her family
God forbid something that like that
would happen I've said repeatedly on the
record that I think that that girl
should be able to get an abortion if she
and her family so choose to do so but
let's talk about that case because why
was a 10 year old girl raped here we go
Community raped in our state in the
league the thing the media and Congress
and Ryan they talk about this all the
time the thing they never mentioned is
that poor girl was raped by an illegal
alien somebody that should have never
been in this state in the first place
you voted so many times against border
wall funding so many times for amnesty
Tim if you had done your job she would
have never been raped in the first place
do your job on border security Don't
lecture me about opinions I don't
actually have thank you Mr Vance we do
intend to get to immigration later but
we do want to move on to a new topic
here we want to get into some of the
claims made by by each of you about the
other one during the it's kind of crazy
not to let them respond to that uh Tim
Ryan says you're a Silicon Valley
vulture capitalist who is out of touch
with the needs of everyday Ohioans
explain to voters why you think that's
wrong well there are a couple things so
Tim Ryan has this whole thing in his
campaign that I'm actually an out of
state California and even though I was
born and raised in this state and the
reason I left when I was 18 was to
enlist in the United States Marine Corps
that was the first time I ever left the
state of Ohio I went to Ohio State
University I started a business here I
raised my three small children here uh
and and this is a ridiculous accusation
from a guy by the way 20 years in
Washington who has never actually had to
employ people and has never actually
created a single job my business in Ohio
has been involved in investing and
supporting the creation of nearly a
thousand jobs just in our state and jobs
elsewhere as well I believe in investing
in our communities and I've actually put
my money where my mouth is taking a big
risk by getting out of Silicon Valley
and starting a business here in Ohio and
I want to be clear about something Tim
Ryan represents a congressional district
that has lost 50 000 jobs just in his
time in office those of us who create
jobs know what it's like when you have
bad policies and we know what it's like
when you have good policies I'd like Tim
Ryan to lecture me on my business
background a little bit less and maybe
explain why the guy who's the biggest
fighter of China had his own
congressional district lose tens of
thousands of good manufacturing jobs to
China just in your time can I answer
that yeah the problem is and you know
why who's like that
JD make money off of investing in China
he in his first Venture Capital fund
Investments you invested into China and
you have these you have the one that
ships jobs from China to manufacture
things that go to like I don't know if
it's veil or some kind of ski Resort or
something like a consultant so I'm
telling you this line so I don't
actually know I'm telling you JD you've
not denied investing in the China and
you're talking about illegal immigrants
he has businesses in Ohio that actually
hire foreign workers do you think we're
stupid JD and we're not I'm just telling
you that you are so you're from Silicon
Valley you don't understand what's going
on here in Ohio you invest in the China
you hire foreign workers and you are
funded by Silicon Valley billionaire he
gave you 15 million dollars
funded your primary Mitch McConnell is
giving you 40 million dollars all
corporate money from the corporations
who ship jobs overseas now you want to
parachute into Ohio and you want to try
to buy a senancy it's not going to work
because everybody can sniff it out that
candidates all you want to do is and Tim
how many tens of millions of dollars
have you gotten from Apple from Google
from the companies that have shipped a
lot of jobs to China you can't even name
the company that I allegedly invested in
that ships jobs in China
foreign
making statements during the campaign Mr
Vance in an April interview with Gateway
pundit you suggested that President
Biden is intentionally allowing fentanyl
to cross the border in order to Target
and kill Mega voters do you believe the
president is trying to kill people who
did not vote for him well I didn't say
that he was intentionally killing people
what I said Colleen is that his rhetoric
on how he views people who didn't vote
for him is totally beyond the pale and
totally unacceptable and by the way Tim
Ryan who runs all these TV commercials
saying that he wants to appeal to Trump
voters wants to appeal to Republicans
also says that he wants to kill and
confront what is it the Maga movement
Tim that's not exactly the rhetoric of a
unifier what I do think is that the end
result of Joe Biden's policies and the
end result of his rhetoric is that one
we hate each other a lot more than we
did two years ago that's a significant
failure of leadership and yes the
fentanyl crisis is way worse than it was
two years ago why is it way worse
because Tim Ryan and Joe Biden have
conspired together to reject every
border wall funding proposal to reject
every proposal to cut off the amnesty to
reject every proposal that would
actually secure our border and stop the
flow of these illegal drugs thanks Mr
Vince Congressman Ryan we want to get to
you here uh it was alluded to but on
MSNBC you said Americans need to quote
kill and confront the extremist movement
within the GOP in the past you've
condemned Donald Trump's rhetoric as
having the possibility to incite
violence is that similar language that
you once condemned movement kill and
confront the extremist movement of which
JD Vance unfortunately is a part of
right who says that the president of the
United States is intentionally trying to
kill people with fentanyl who says that
the election was stolen JD Vance does
who runs around with Ron DeSantis the
governor of Florida who wants to ban
books running around with Lindsey Graham
who wants a National Abortion ban you're
running around with Marjory Taylor green
who's the absolute looniest politician
in America this is a dangerous group and
we do need to confront it and that's why
I'm running
to represent the exhausted majority
Democrats Republicans and independents
candidates against the extremists we are
going to turn now to foreign policy last
week President Biden made the shocking
claim that we are on the verge of
Armageddon the reason being Vladimir
Putin's threat to use nuclear weapons in
Ukraine so this question is for both of
you if that were to happen if Putin were
to use nuclear weapons how should the
United States respond and we begin with
you Congressman Ryan well it would have
to be a an aggressive response I don't
think we're at that point where Vladimir
Putin will I hope he doesn't we should
be prepared for all contingencies should
he do that and it should be a Swift and
significant response we cannot have a
butcher like Vladimir Putin rolling in
the Ukraine what he's done there is an
absolute atrocity and the fact that he's
killed innocent in people innocent women
innocent girls is is is so heartbreaking
and the fact that guys like JD Vance
have said I don't care what's going on
in Ukraine I will tell you I've been the
Parma I've been to Cleveland I've met
with the refugees you know who I meet
with the women and the daughters and
sons because the husbands are in Ukraine
fighting that's the kind of Freedom we
need to support and JD Vance would let
Putin roll right through Ukraine and I'm
just telling you that we got to have a
strong military and we've got to make
sure that we can push back people like
Vladimir Putin if they try to invade a
freedom-loving country and JD Vance is
weak on this same question to you then
Mr Vance how should we respond if
Vladimir Putin uses nuclear weapons in
Ukraine so the answer is that nobody
knows how we should respond if he uses
nuclear weapons now let me just address
this what Vladimir Putin did was
discussing and wrong and we all have to
admire what the ukrainians have done as
they've repelled this Invasion but let's
just take stock of something that Tim
Ryan said and Tim I don't think that you
meant anything by it but I want to hone
in on this because it reflects the
failure of the bipartisan foreign policy
establishment in our country the same
people who got us into Iraq and the same
people who got us into Afghanistan for
20 years he said that if Vladimir Putin
uses nuclear weapons we should have a
strong response what exactly does that
mean does that mean we're in a nuclear
shooting War I have three kids and I'm
running to be the United States senator
for the state of Ohio I want to protect
those children and I want a foreign
policy establishment that puts the
interests of our Citizens First what
everybody has been doing and I've been
at the very Forefront of this saying we
need to de-escalate the situation
Vladimir Putin launching nuclear weapons
against Ukraine is something we have to
do everything possible to prevent and
right now everybody seems to be
everybody in the Bible administration at
least seems to be sleepwalking into a
nuclear war that is the worst possible
thing that could happen we have to do
everything to prevent it I think this is
just quickly because this is an
important Point here if JD had his way
Putin would be through Ukraine at this
point he'd be going into Poland like we
if he's using nuclear weapons what do
you what do you want us to do I mean you
can't just send hopes and prayers
instead of launching tons of money into
Ukraine thank you we do want to we want
to continue on foreign policy here we
want to move to another part of the
globe President Biden also recently made
headlines saying he would use American
military force to defend Taiwan if China
were to attack the question again goes
to both of you should America defend
Taiwan Congressman Ryan we start with
you I believe that we should I believe
that we should this is uh you know we
have a commitment again we do not want
to be at war with China we need to
out-compete them economically we need to
make sure that we invest into the United
States and I'll compete them but we do
have commitments and that's why I have
always supported strong investments into
our defense including president Trump's
defense budget president Trump's
initiative with the space force we've
got to continue to invest into our Navy
love to get the ship uh you know repairs
uh done here in Lorraine Ohio and in
Lordstown Ohio where we're talking about
making sure we can take our ships out
the problem now we take a ship out of
the water it's got four years before we
can fix it and rebuild it so we have
these commitments but we've got to have
a strong military we've got to have a
strong defense because you never know
what circumstance we're going to be in
and I will tell you that China is no
joke they are investing heavily into
their military and you can't see it all
thank you Congressman Mr Vance same
question to the United States militarily
defend Taiwan if they're attacked budget
yes taiwan's a much different situation
from Russian Ukraine because of how
important it is to American National
Security Now the policy of this country
bipartisan by the way over 40 years was
strategic ambiguity the idea is that we
wouldn't commit to doing one thing or
the other but everybody recognized that
we would try to do something maybe not
send military troops in a ground war but
we would do something to try to defend
Taiwan the thing we need to do is get
ourselves in a position where we don't
have to rely on the Chinese and the
Taiwanese in the first place the reason
why Taiwan is different is because they
make so many of our semiconductors our
computer chips the entire modern economy
would collapse without it we got to
bring that stuff back to this country
Rob Portman Tim mentioned earlier
senator of course of our state a guy who
endorsed me and was critical in getting
the chips bill passed that's the sort of
policy you need to break our Reliance on
China it's a great piece of legislation
we just got to go much further so we
don't have to defend Island countries if
it's not in our core National interest a
gentlemen we're going to switch topics
once again and our next topic is lgbtq
plus rights and for our question you
take a look at your monitor candidates
we send it to Nisha Petty home from The
Next Star station WDTN in Dayton
equality Ohio says there are more than a
half million lgbtq plus citizens living
here outgoing Senator Rob Portman is
co-sponsoring the marriage equality act
that will codify same-sex marriage are
you ready to support that bill why or
why not Mr Vance we start with you yeah
so I've come out against this bill and I
don't think it's actually about gay
marriage it's not about same-sex
marriage or same-sex equality look gay
marriage is the law to land in this
country and I'm not trying to do
anything to change that but if you look
at the specific bill that's being
proposed it wouldn't just codify
something that's already enacted in law
it would actually make it easier for
both the government and a lot of private
parties to sue religious organizations
if those religious organizations don't
comply with the dictates of the federal
government I'm a devout Christian and I
think it's in town it's pretty good to
protect religious liberty in this
country we remember about 10 years ago
when the when the Obama Administration
I'm sure supported by Tim Ryan went
after a group of Catholic nuns because
that Catholic nunnery wanted to run its
organization the way that confirmed with
its religious beliefs that should be
okay in this country and the problem
with this legislation is it's going to
unleash a wave of litigation against our
churches our religious organizations our
mosques our synagogues everything that's
why I don't think it's a great idea
thank you Mr Vance Congressman Ryan same
question I voted for that in the House
of Representatives I will support
codifying that into the Senate but only
only JD Vance can say
that that the bill that codifies
same-sex marriage is not about same-sex
marriage
only JD you're gonna you're the only one
JD Vance again can actually say that
it's unbelievable the problem we have
here is we have 15 000 marriages uh here
in Ohio and when you read Justice
Thomas's opinion on abortion which JD
Vance wants to celebrate it also
included in their nullifying these
marriages and it also included in their
getting rid of protections around birth
control Yep this is what I'm trying to
explain to Ohioans that JD Vance is
Extreme on these issues no exceptions
for rape or incest he called rape
inconvenient he can be said he denied it
but it's on tape right now he says he's
not for same-sex marriage he's going
right down the line with the absolute
most extremists the guys who want to ban
books and everything else those are the
guys you bring into the state to
campaign for you JD these are extreme
positions that Ohioans are rejecting
well I want to just point out something
about what Tim very quickly sir yes
Colleen thank you we're gonna point out
something that Tim Ryan just did one I
answered the question about same-sex
marriage and I identified very
specifically a couple of problems with
the legislation Tim didn't address that
he just pretended that it didn't exist
because here's the problem with Tim Ryan
he spent 20 years in Washington DC he
actually doesn't care about the details
of public policy and I'm sure he didn't
even read the bill that he voted on what
he does is he reads the canned lines
that his Consultants give him you could
respond on to the argument that I made
Tim instead you decided to pretend again
that I have views I don't actually hold
so you can't look it's insulting voters
deserve somebody who actually respects
their views and speaks honestly to them
about the issues that's not what Tim's
doing tonight we want to get something
else on the record while we're on this
topic the Senate has a unique role my
feel is this is pretty even so far tell
me what you think marriage equality as
the congressman mentioned could be
Revisited by the Supreme Court will that
be a litmus test for you if you are in
the position of evaluating a supreme
court nominee and we begin with you Mr
Vance I don't like any litmus test for
any Supreme Court nominations I just
want good judges who interpret the
Constitution that's what I really want
and look Tim Ryan just accused me of
being extreme on the LGBT issue this is
a guy voted just a couple of months ago
right for the equality act the so-called
equality act that would literally remove
Federal funding for free and reduced
lunch programming for schools that don't
let biological males participate in
biological female sports the extremist
here Tim is you and again I don't expect
you to actually answer the substance of
what I said but let's just at least be
honest with voters about what our actual
views are and we are on the litmus test
question and you can respond to him on
that as well yeah I I will have a litmus
test I will have a litmus test on Roe v
Wade I'll have a litmus test on uh the
same-sex marriage I'll have a litmus
test on birth control we cannot keep
going down this road of taking away
rights the Dodge decision was the
absolute first decision where the
Supreme Court is taking rights away from
people that's it's not right you know we
don't want doctors in our bedrooms we
don't want doctors uh in our in our uh
doc or uh I'm sorry politicians in our
bedrooms and politicians in our doctors
offices that's not what we want and
that's what that's what this group of
people who have taken over the Supreme
Court and taken over state legislators
want they want control they want to
control women they want to tell you what
kind of marriage you can have they want
to tell you whether or not you can use
birth control and look the reality of it
is we got to get the government out of a
lot of these decisions and let the local
governments make the the school and the
education decisions thank you candidates
we are going to move on to another topic
immigration it's something that comes up
a lot on the campaign Trails come up a
lot already tonight and it's something
you may have a chance to weigh in on if
you're elected to the Senate we begin
with representative Ryan you recently
did an interview with our Columbus
Station calling for continued
construction of parts of a border wall
where you say where experts say it makes
sense you don't hear many Democrats
calling for continued construction of a
wall in fact when former president Trump
proposed the wall you're one of the
Democrats who called it a quote vanity
project what changed well I think to
have a wall from sea to shining sea
doesn't make any sense you can't put a
wall in the middle of the Rio Grande
River but if you can put a barrier up
somewhere that can prevent people from
coming over I'm all for it but El Chapo
digs under that uh barrier as well which
is why I've always supported increased
funding for border patrol I started the
Border technology caucus to figure out
how we can use technology that we have
in the United States to prevent this
fentanyl from coming in that goes from
China to Mexico into the country and now
even more so with rainbow fentanyl which
is scary for so many people it's got to
be a comprehensive approach and then
figure out who's in the country right if
they're here pay a fine pay back taxes
you know pass a background check and
come into the country I also have a
resolution designating fentanyl as a
weapon of mass destruction so we could
have a whole of government approach
making sure we stop it this is in
contrast
to our guy here who is investing into
companies that hire foreign workers has
a real tough position on immigration and
any hires people in his in investing
companies that hire foreign workers real
tough position on China
and then he invests in China and
manufactures products and sends them
back thank you Congressman uh Mr Vance I
want to get to you we have a question
for you on this you call for reform to
our legal immigration system as well on
your website but you say we should only
allow immigrants in if they contribute
quote something meaningful to our
country how would you define what is
Meaningful can you give specifics good
question well I think skills and ability
to learn or already know the English
language that's all very important I'm a
big fan of what Tom Cotton has proposed
called the raise act but look I mean the
legal immigration problem I know very
personally and I've been affected by it
very personally my mom struggled with
addiction for a big chunk of my early
childhood and I'm very proud to say by
the way she's been clean and sober for
seven years I'm sure she's watching
right now I love you mom
um but one of the great blessings for
our family is that we got a second
chance with Mom we got that seven years
clean and sober because the poison
that's being that was coming into the
country thank God 15 years ago was not
nearly as dangerous as the poison that's
coming into the country today Tim Ryan
has done nothing to stop the flow of
fentanyl he talks about wanting to
support a stronger border he talks about
wanting to be by why do they all say
fentanyl isn't it Fentanyl border
problem has got worse and worse and
worse I don't care about what you want
to do Tim I care about what have you
done what have you actually done to
reduce the flow of fentanyl so that
people like my family are not as
affected by this terrible addiction
crisis that's the thing I really really
worry about here is that look we all
agree okay we want a strong border we
want to make sure El Chapo is going to
of course we believe those things Tim
Ryan has had 20 years to get something
done and he just hasn't done it so
Congressman Ryan we're going to give you
a chance to answer that as well as our
next question which is that the vice
president Kamala Harris said just last
month that the southern border is secure
so do you agree with her and how do you
respond to the accusations that just
came from Mr Vance Kamal Harris is
absolutely wrong on that it's not secure
we have a lot of work to do I'm not here
to just get in a fight or just toe the
Democratic party line I'm here to speak
the truth we do have more work to do
which is why I have a resolution to
designate fentanyl as a weapon of mass
destruction which is why vote for more
border patrol why why vote for a barrier
why vote for technology and started the
Border technology caucus so that's what
I have done you know what I haven't done
I didn't start a fake non-profit
pretending like I was going to help
people with addiction like JD Vance did
literally started a non-profit and
didn't spend one nickel on anybody in
fact he brought in somebody from Purdue
Pharma to be the spokesperson
for the non-profit the same drug company
big Pharma the big drug company that had
all the pill Mills going got everybody
addicted one million people died JD one
million people died and you started a
non-profit to try to take advantage of
people in Ohio and you know what all you
did with it was launch your political
career his campaign manager worked for
that non-profit he ran a poll to check
his own standing from that non-profit
I'm not going to take a back seat to you
or anybody else on fentanyl drugs or
immigration or anything else somebody
that would what kind of man would start
a fake non-profit
not spend any money on anything none of
this is true of course and here and here
and here's the here's the problem of
what Tim Ryan said it's shameful for you
attack to attack me given that my family
was affected by this problem I put
eighty thousand dollars of my own money
into that non-profit organization Tim
and it absolutely did help people now
here's the thing if you're in Ohio and
you've seen these ridiculous commercials
that Tim Ryan runs telling dishonest
truth dishonest lies about my non-profit
organization it's paid by pharmaceutical
blood money because the very same
corporations that cause this poison to
come into our country in the first place
have funded your campaign to the tune of
tens of thousands of dollars why are the
people who've gotten rich off the opioid
epidemic funding Tim Ryan and attacking
me the answer is obvious because this
guy is the biggest fan of Pharma and
he's the biggest fan of a legal Pharma
which is the Mexican drug cartels that
are bringing this poison into our
country I just need a chance to respond
to that my record
is impeccable clearly it's not
Pharmaceuticals and taking on big Pharma
okay is that why they give you tens of
thousands of dollars I don't vote with
them I don't vote with them but you do
take their money just a couple weeks ago
we passed a uh Medicare reform provision
that for the first time in decades we
will be able to negotiate down drug
prices big farmer didn't like that
fought a tooth and nail I voted against
them we capped prescription drug costs
in the Medicare program for seniors to
two thousand dollars my mom falls into
the donut hole she'll pay a thousand a
month of prescription drugs we capped it
to 2 000 a year I helped get that passed
I took on the pharmaceutical company
insulin we got it to 35 bucks for
Medicare recipients I fought for that
and I got it so time and time again I
have voted against the pharmaceutical
but this is the smoke and mirrors that
our guy likes to put up here you started
a sham non-profit didn't do anything and
had a spokesperson it was a mouthpiece
for big Pharma
thousand dollars that he gets our next
topic the recent fatal police shootings
of jaland Walker in Akron and Donovan
Lewis in Columbus sparked renewed
concern and fear of law enforcement in
communities of color many activists call
for a complete overhaul of policing in
America Mr Vance back in 2017 you said
quote there are legitimate concerns that
a lot of black Americans have that
they're not treated fairly by some
members of the police it has been five
years since you said that is that still
your position today of course Colleen I
mean look I've talked to a number of
police officers and you know one of the
interesting things I've heard from our
police officers and of course I've been
endorsed by the Statewide Fraternal
Order of Police of course because during
the rioting a couple of years ago Tim
Ryan threw these guys under the bus and
I didn't but one of the things I hear
from them is that they want to do more
community policing they actually want to
do more engagement whether it's black
white or brown with people in the
community that they're actually trying
to keep saying safe the problem is it's
really hard to do that when you're 25 30
under staff so we got to increase
funding for law enforcement we've got to
protect law enforcement and we've got to
do something that Tim Ryan failed to do
which is stop the leadership of this
country from going after qualified
immunity here's what qualified immunity
does it provides legal protections for
our police officers when they do their
jobs they need that so that they can
attract the right people and so that
they can focus on keeping people safe
not litigation from ridiculous activists
I think if we Empower our law
enforcement look you're always going to
have bad apples 99 of our cops are great
people if we make their job easier we're
actually going to allay the concerns of
a lot of heavily police communities
we're also going to make all of us less
or all of us more safe Congressman Ryan
along those same lines in many cities
police departments are struggling a
crime is going up but the number of
police officers is going down amid this
increased scrutiny that he alluded to
officers are retiring early and and
police departments are having problems
attracting new police officers so what's
the solution to that problem well I've
tried to be a part of the solution here
we need more cops we need better paid
cops and yeah we got to get rid of bad
cops we need more technology and
Equipment I've brought back almost 500
million dollars for law enforcement here
in Ohio and when I get to the Senate I
will continue to do that I was the lead
advocate for putting money into the
rescue package for state and local
government Governor dewine is now going
around the state passing out money for
law enforcement that's Federal money I
agree that the governor should do that
and I'm glad he's doing it but that's
Federal money that I helped get into
that bill so that law enforcement has
the resources they need and we have to
keep helping out but I will say this I
am not going to take it back seat to JD
Vance on law enforcement or anything
else for that matter the fact that on
January 6th
we had 140 cops United States Capitol
Police get injured during the
Insurrection when they tried to
overthrow the government beat them
upside the head with lead pipes spraying
with pepper spray the one video we saw
the cop got jammed into the the door
right JD Vance
raised money for the legal defense fund
of the insurrectionists this is the kind
of extremism JD that we wholly reject
you have video posts don't even try to
deny it and we got we got yours we got
your Twitter posts and everything else
everybody's seen it he said help these
guys with their legal defense on now you
can you imagine one guy saying out of
one side of his mouth he's pro-cop and
on the other side of his mouth he's
raising money for the insurrectionists
who were beating up the Capitol Police
the one guy he tried to raise money for
got four years in prison solid this is
ridiculous I'm not taking a back seat to
you I brought 500 million dollars back
to fund police in Ohio so I you know
I've I've got a I've got three little
kids including a two-year-old and one of
the things that's true of toddlers is
also apparently true of career
politicians is that they accuse you of
doing the very thing that they do
themselves all the time at the height at
the height Tim of the BLM riots I've
condemned political violence whether it
comes from the left or the right but at
the height of the BLM riots where they
were riding and looting and burning down
America's cities Ohio cities and small
towns Tim Ryan threw the police under
the bus he attacked them as the new Jim
Crow as systemically racist and he voted
for legislation that would have stripped
funding from them and redirected it
towards litigation defense this is
another example it was JD fundraising
for the insurrectionists or not bad if
you actually tried to do the things you
talk about wanting to do you wouldn't be
half bad the problem is you got 20 years
and you failed to do any of it thank you
candidates we are now going to move on
to our next topic and for that we turn
once again to Nisha Petty home from our
next star station in Dayton WDTN
gentlemen if you look at your monitor
poly has indicated Americans are
increasingly concerned about threats to
our democracy we posed that question to
you what do you feel is the biggest
threat to democracy right now and
Congressman Ryan this goes first to you
I think I think it's extremism that we
saw during the Insurrection and you
could see that JD didn't answer it he
did raise money for the insurrectionists
he's all in with those people who are
the election deniers who call in the
question the most fundamental act we
have the foundation of this country he's
called into question the presidential
election that's a threat to our
democracy and running around with people
who want to ban books and get the
government in our bedroom and in our
doctor's offices but I tell you what I
think politically is is a huge threat to
our democracy and that's guys that don't
have the guts to stand up to their own
party okay now I've run against Nancy
Pelosi I have taken on Bernie Sanders I
have opposed job guiding on numerous
pieces of legislation that he wants to
try to promote and push and I've agreed
with Donald Trump on trade renegotiating
NAFTA uh being firmer on China defense
all bad things by the way but it is Ohio
all the rest and I think the problem is
when you have guys like JD Vance who
can't stand up to anybody like just a
few weeks ago in in Youngstown on the
stage
uh Donald Trump said to JD Vance all you
do is kiss my ass to get my support
there it is he said that that's bad
because that means JD Vance is going to
do whatever he wants Mitch McConnell's
giving him 40 million he's going to do
what he wants and Peter Thiel gave him a
15 million he's going to do what he
wants and here's the thing that's most
troubling about this
lack of Courage is that after Trump took
JD Vance's dignity from him on the stage
in Youngstown JD Vance got back up on
stage and said start shaking his hand
take a picture saying hey aren't we
having a great time here tonight I don't
know anybody I grew up with I don't know
anybody I went to high school with that
would allow somebody to take their
dignity like that and then get back up
on stage we need leaders who have
courage to take on their own party yeah
and I've proven that and he was called
an ass kisser by the former president so
our biggest threat to democracy sure if
you would like to answer that first and
then some of his accusations so I will
answer the question Colleen because I
think it's important for the voters for
us to actually answer the questions but
first of all I'm not going to take
lectures on Dignity and self-respect
from a guy caught on video kissing up to
Chuck Schumer and begging him for a
promotion to his next job that's the
kind of guy that Tim Ryan is now he just
said it's so funny we're getting close
to Halloween and Tim Ryan is put on a
costume where he pretends to be a reason
reasonable moderate but in fact he he
said he stands up to his own party the
last two Congress is Tim you voted for
Nancy Pelosi and Joe Biden 100 you
consistently tow the party line on every
single issue I wish that you were the
reasonable moderate you said you were
because then Youngstown may not lost 50
000 manufacturing jobs during her during
her 20 years
on the threat to democracy Colleen so he
just accused me of being an election
denier this is a term that Democrats
throw around here's the thing I've said
about the 2020 election and it really
implicates big Tech I think we have
great elections in the state of Ohio and
I encourage everybody even if you're
going to vote for this guy to get out
there and vote by November the 8th but
here's the thing we know because
Facebook has told us that leadership of
the FBI approached Facebook and told
them to censor information that was
negative about Joe Biden about Hunter
Biden's corrupt business dealings you
cannot have a multinational corporation
that's in bed with the Communist Chinese
that's censoring information about one
of America's political parties and doing
it in a way that interferes with
people's knowledge and ultimately
people's votes that's a threat to
democracy big Tech has way too much
power and it benefits the Democrats
thank you Mr Vance we do want to follow
up with you you are it's come up here
you're endorsed by and you've been
campaigning with former president Donald
Trump he is facing multiple criminal
investigations is there anything the
former president has done that concerns
you I mean is there anything he's done
that's concerned me why don't we let the
criminal investigations actually play
out because I was alive during 2016 and
what I saw was consistently rumors that
finally Donald Trump was going to be
indicted that he was going to be accused
of something legitimately criminal of
course Tim Ryan despite his commercials
voted to impeach him twice uh I I have
seen nothing that suggests that
President United States should be thrown
in prison and most importantly here if
you're going to make accusations like
this the attorney general United States
mayor Garland one of the most political
actors in the history of American
Justice if you want to go after a former
president a likely a possible future
president or at least a future political
candidate you've got to tell the
American people why we have really
corrupt leadership at at the Department
of Justice and that's a problem
Congressman Ryan he's not really an
Nationwide address President Biden
called the Maga Republicans the threat
to American democracy was he right
those people
who stormed the capital are a threat to
the Democracy those people who say that
the election uh was fraudulent are a
threat to our democracy if we lose the
the foundational element of this country
our vote our elections then we lose
everything and we got very close to that
on January 6 when people wanted to to
kill Mike overthrow the peaceful
transition this is not some throwaway
line and that's what I'm I want people
in Ohio to understand this is the crowd
that JD is running around with the
election deniers the extremists with
that's not Ohio that's not Rob Portman
that's not George voinovich that's not
Sherrod brown right that's that's the
though that's not for us he's running
with an extreme element here that's very
very
dangerous first of all Rob Portman
endorsed me of course and I find it
interesting how preoccupied you are with
this at a time when people can't afford
groceries people can't afford to walk
down the street safely let's focus on
the significant issues right now thank
you Candace we do have one more question
on this topic before we move on it has
come up a few times here already uh and
this is to both of you do you both
pledge to accept the results of this
senate election Mr Vance of course Mr
Ryan yes in the interest of time and we
are running tight on time we're going to
ask you a few more rapid fire questions
give you each about 20 to 30 seconds to
answer so we can get some more topics in
first question it goes to both of you do
you support the federal
decriminalization of marijuana
Congressman Ryan I do I support
legalization of marijuana I think the
fact that we spend tens of billions of
dollars putting people in prison for
marijuana crimes is ridiculous we should
Legalize It we should tax it we should
use it to fund our schools and we should
make sure we retrain all these people
who've had their lives destroyed by
going to prison for a marijuana crime Mr
Vance it's a one I think it should be a
state's issue States should make these
decisions second I don't want anybody
going to prison for smoking a joint
that's not at all what I want to do the
third thing is we got to be careful here
not to be soft on crime because a lot of
times you'll hear somebody thrown in
prison for smoking a joint which I just
said I don't think that's a good idea
that's not something that we should be
doing but that's just true on paper and
if you look at the underlying charge
you'll see it wasn't just that they
smoked a joint it's that they smoked a
joint and then beat an elderly woman
over the head with a pistol those people
should go to prison and just having pled
down to a so-called non-violent drug
offense they should still be going to
jail we have to be careful about how we
do this we don't want to be solved on
crime for people like that Mr Vance if
your party wins the majority who should
be the Senate leader look whoever runs
uh I don't want Chuck Schumer to be the
Senate Majority Leader that's for sure
the guy that Tim Ryan says he wants to
be his boss presumably Mitch McConnell
will run if somebody else runs we can
have that conversation but I know I
don't want to be the Senate Majority
Leader that's Chuck Schumer well I'll go
back to you Mr Ryan you told me in an
interview about a week ago and you
mentioned it tonight it's time for the
Old Guard to be gone you mentioned Nancy
Pelosi Trump Biden should Chuck Schumer
be gone as well well I'm going to vote
for the person who's going to give the
absolute best deal to Ohio you know JD's
talking about a joke that I made but the
reality of it is I have been a pain in
the rear end to Nancy Pelosi and if
Chuck shoulders I will be a pain in the
rear and the Hem too I'm for Ohio I
don't kiss anyone's ass like him Ohio
needs an ass kicker not an ass kisser
whoa okay thank you candidates another
reverse line another one for you here do
you believe in term limits at the
federal level we'll start with Mr Vance
yeah absolutely I think we had term
limits frankly we would get career
politicians who've never had a real job
out of Washington DC when they fail and
they'd have to go get a real job I think
that Youngstown would be much better off
if Tim Ryan had to go back to Youngstown
to work in the private sector than spend
all of his time in Washington DC
right I think turn limits are at The
Ballot Box I'm just going to say
something to JD Vance you know my family
has done nothing but served their whole
lives that's where I learned it my
grandfather at his church he was a lead
usher 1045 Mass ran the beer tent my mom
helped with the church my grandmother
helped at the church I'd play on the Our
Lady of Mount Carmel playground my
grandfather would be there painting the
rectory you know we give back I'm not
going to apologize for spending 20 years
of my adult life slogging away to try to
help one of the hardest economically hit
regions of Ohio and dedicated my life to
help that region come back you got to be
ashamed of yourself JD you went off to
California you were drinking wine and
eating cheese and you said I don't even
feel comfortable in Ohio anymore
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna sit here and let you demean my
service that I learned from my family
that when I went to Catholic school we
had to spend time going to help people
it's called senior service I had to put
on my football jersey and go serve in
the community this is an extension I
admire the spirit of service no I don't
admire is the failure of accomplishment
look at how Youngstown has done during
your leadership that's what I don't
admire
we want to get to your closing
statements so we thank you both very
much we are going to give each of you
one minute here for your closing
statements as agreed we are going to
start with Congressman Ryan you have 60
Seconds
America is a great place right this
country has fed more people clothed more
people cured more people and liberated
more people than all the other countries
in the world combined
and we have to rebuild the Great
American middle class Ohio has always
led the way we've got great things
happening in Ohio but I met a woman in
Marietta who was a single mom who had to
travel two hours to work and two hours
back that's who I'm fighting for that's
why we went all in on electric vehicles
where we now have four vehicles and the
old General Motors Lordstown plant we're
manufacturing the jobs of the future
solar panels in Toledo natural gas in
the Southeast the chips manufacturing
plant is going to be a blockbuster
average wage 135 000 a year battery
plant in Mahoning Valley look we have an
opportunity to be the manufacturing
Powerhouse of the world the Arsenal of
energy I will never forget where I came
from and if you want to help this
campaign go to temporoh.com chip in
volunteer we're going to build a
movement of the exhausted majority
Democrats Republicans and independents
to move this state into the future and
your final statement Mr Vance
look 20 years ago I enlisted in the
United States Marine Corps right that
very same year Tim Ryan went to
Washington DC where he has been failing
at his basic job for 20 years Talk's a
big game but at the record of
accomplishment just isn't there I think
there's something very basic here I
think that people deserve certain things
Ohioans deserves certain things from
their Federal leadership they deserve to
go to the grocery store and be able to
afford food without it breaking the bank
they deserve streets that you can walk
down safely they deserve a country that
has a border I promise we may not always
agree on everything but I'll never
forget where I came from and I'll never
stop fighting to achieve those things
for the people who deserve them this is
such an important election I'd encourage
people to go to jdvance.com and support
me but at the end of the day the
question here is whether we need new
leadership in this state double down on
the last two years of failed leadership
or take this country in a different
direction I thank you all for listening
I thank you for watching and I hope to
earn your vote God bless you guys thank
you Mr Vamps and that concludes
tonight's Ohio United yeah so listen uh
I think JD Vance did well enough that
this probably won't torpedo his campaign
he's leading by 1.4 on average right now
and I don't know that he did anything in
particular here
to destroy that uh that's my that's my
instinct and this isn't particularly
good for Tim Ryan but it's very close
it's very close
and everybody should vote
and then we will have an outcome and
then we will go from there
uh
uh I think that's where I will leave it
many many many more debates coming up
this week and next week and the week
after I hope you will join me for them
and that does it for tonight see
everybody very soon